welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 82.
i had another chance to have my mom on
my podcast where we continue our
discussions from the first time she came
on
in march of 2021. this episode is
actually
from march but i saved the release until
now i wanted to sneak one in before i
left toronto
we spoke about her spirituality religion
meditation
teaching children mom and dad's hell's
angel biker landlord
and more fun stories if you enjoy these
podcasts please remember to hit
subscribe
this episode is brought to you by
understandmyself.com
i've spoken a lot about self-authoring
but understand myself is actually my
favorite product that my dad has
it's the most accurate and
scientifically valid personality test
out
there i'm looking at you myers-briggs
you'll get a specialized personalized
report after completing the
understandmyself.com personality test
that will help you understand your
personality in greater detail
and help you grow your understanding of
others it
doesn't just tell you good things either
it tells you where you're going to have
personality troubles
the understandmyself.com also now allows
you to create a relationship report with
your partner
once you and your partner have completed
your own assessments you can connect
them to create a report providing a
description of what you might expect
from being in a relationship together
good luck go to understandmyself.com
and get a better understanding of how
you function and interact with people
code mp for 10
off and so they know that you came from
here i hope you enjoyed this episode
[Music]
tammy peterson welcome back to my
podcast thank you for having me michaela
i'm so excited this is actually pretty
fun
sure and people seem to like the last
one
i'm glad that's nice so let's start off
i asked my instagram this is where i
usually go for questions but i asked my
instagram
if they had questions and they actually
had really good questions
super polite questions and so i chose
some from there and some that i had
but i think we can get through a bunch
of interesting things okay let's go okay
we're going to start with this is going
to be it's going to be all over the
place
so i hope you're okay with that okay
advice for yourself in your 30s
so is this 30 now or 30 when i was 30.
let's do
let's do let's do if you went back
and you needed some advice what would
you give yourself back then
okay things have definitely changed
slightly
yeah they've changed a lot yeah in 30
years but anyway
um has it been 30 years i'm jesus i'm
almost 30.
yeah okay it's been 30 years okay okay
so yeah going back in time then
yes the long ways right okay so
be gentle with i would have been more
gentle with myself
and my
um expectations of myself
um you know it's it's really
you're getting into a world that's so
new
when you have kids and a husband
you've never done it before so having
any expectations for either of those is
a real
setback so
i mean looking at the fairy tale version
of what it should be and then
any expectations you might have is a
setback
because then you're always gonna be
disappointed
right so you're setting yourself up for
disappointment when you have
expectations
and so i think and if you have dreams
for your children
that's also an expectation and so
it's very difficult right because you
want to have dreams
you you do have dreams for your marriage
and for your children but those are
fantasies they are not reality
and they are not to be taken seriously
so you can do those things but you gotta
know
they don't count they're kind of fun to
do to have dreams about what your
relationship's going to be like and what
your kids are going to do but
they have absolutely no foundation in
reality
and so anybody who's disappointed that
things didn't turn out the way they
dreamt it i mean they were it was a pipe
dream to begin with
you got to stay in the moment with your
children and children live in the moment
so didn't just uh in regards to julian
and i did we turn out completely
different did you have some sort of
expectation that we just didn't
i had not live up to about that we were
just dead i had an expectation when you
were
a kid and you got sick that i
i noticed i had expectations then
i you know you started out being
somebody who wanted to
do ballet and wanted to be uh
an avid sportsman you know you were
really
uh aggressive you wanted
to win you want to win yeah and you're
still you still have that same spirit
and i think what you're doing now
suits you you were entrepreneurial from
the beginning
like really from the beginning it was
selling dr seuss books yeah
you know having you know coin
collections and
you were just always uh into something
creative and so that
i just saw in you and it's grown which
has been lovely but i had
some expectations that were
really brought home to me when when you
had arthritis and then
the physical things that you were doing
you had to limit
and so and as far as julian goes
nothing really there was no trauma
really with him
so who he is
is you know he played guitar he sang he
still does
so that doesn't seem like a surprise
but i didn't really have expectations
that he was going to be a rock star or
something you know i mean that wasn't
crazy
i hoped he would enjoy singing and that
it would bring him
pleasure and i think it i think it has
and calm it would bring him some sort of
you know and that so but people can get
themselves in trouble with
expectations it's not that surprising
that he had expectations that i would
like not have arthritis
no i know because that was very very
very very unusual
yes it was that's not that's not really
like be prepared for the worst you also
can't live your life being prepared for
the worst
no but although if you all you do those
stay in the present with your kids and
see who they are
that's way more magical than having
expectations about who they might be
you know just seeing who they are is
fascinating right seeing who's who
scarlett is is fascinating
this girl is pretty cool she's so cool
she's sassy
she's so she's so cool she's funny
she likes to have fun she's brave and
she's organized
yeah like to a fault almost well
she likes to see how things go together
and that who knows where that will take
her she likes to see things
go together she likes things to be maybe
she has a very
high aesthetic beauty so that she likes
because i really like when things go
together
you know george doesn't he has a trouble
with how orderly i like things in the
house but i like
beauty oh that's true though you're
you're very orderly though
like very orderly and i like things to
shine
and stuff i just i get a kick out of it
it just makes my heart sing when things
are beautiful
do you think it's a i noticed that when
i got when i stopped being depressed
my room got a lot dirtier yeah and when
i was a kid i can remember
to a fault organizing my room i can
remember staying up at night
sharpening my pencils so that none of
the pencils were dull
like that's a fault of cleanliness right
yeah but if it's two in the morning and
you're sharpening pencils well you
aren't sleeping
that's the problem it's there's a fault
there it's not the sharpening pencil so
much as the not sleeping
you were doing something while you were
not sleeping i guess but
what i meant was do you think your
organization is
towards beauty rather than away from
neuroticism no sometimes i think my
do it organizing things is because i'm
in a difficult situation
okay and so then i'll go and wash dishes
or something because i'm
okay i'm working through something okay
that's what i that's what i noticed with
my depression when it went away it was
like oh my
my room is is dirtier now and it doesn't
bug me and i was like oh my god was i
just keeping it clean because it was
making me anxious
like is that healthy also i
disorderliness i don't know exactly what
it is but when i get up in the morning i
get up first
and whoever went to bed last and left
their clothes and their socks and their
the plate that they used and the glass
they use and everything all
in the living room still how do you
stand that
i don't oh i cannot i know touch it
i don't type it's not my stuff it's not
my stuff it's not my
stuff so i leave it and you know what by
the time that person
is up and running and out the door it's
all cleaned up
it's not my stuff and they and the thing
is
if i cleaned up and they didn't i would
be doing them a disservice
because this is their life and if i
interfere in it i take away
something from them that is something
they can do
so it takes away a little bit of their
responsibility
and that's that's a that's a problem so
i really have to
and i used to do that well how long did
it take you to learn that
oh 60 years oh my god okay because i'm
at least 30 years away from that
well no you weren't because now you're
talking
but it's really it's really good to let
the people around you
make the mistakes they need so they can
learn
you know for he'll get tired of doing
that and eventually he won't do that
anymore because he has to do it every
day
i can't wait 30 years for that well i
don't think it'll be 30 years
probably not okay okay next you know
next question
no now i know that's true okay next
question
there's so many good ones this is a good
one
can you find everything you want in one
individual
i can find it in god ah mom
that's that's the response
okay well we should no we should delve
into that a little bit
you don't find anything in another
individual you find it
in yourself that's where you find things
so yeah you can find
if you can find everything you need in
yourself with
your higher power as
your guide you know because then you
know you're going in the right direction
um okay look look can we pause there for
a sec yeah higher
yeah higher power for people who
don't understand religion or
spirituality or who are
set against the world because i
definitely used to be in that place
then i did a lot of psychedelics and
things switched slightly
but can you describe exactly what you
mean by higher power
like what how does somebody find that
and i don't understand the okay space
between the words
yeah okay so say that you're in a
situation where someone has said
something
that you don't understand and really
what you want to do is set them straight
but but but you pause
because you know that you actually don't
know what
they should be doing in their life you
think you know what they should be doing
in there
it's not going well for you what they're
doing but it's not your business
so you pause so you pause and you pause
and eventually you see what's happening
and they either learn a lesson or what
they were trying to
tell you becomes apparent without you
trying to be the one who makes it right
and so it and that is your higher power
that pause
that where you wait a little bit to see
how the world
organizes itself without you
being the uh organization it does
it does it does and sometimes it can
take a minute
sometimes it can take two weeks what if
you could do it in less than two weeks
you can't though because see the pro
it's like
cleaning up someone else's mess if you
clean up someone else's mess long enough
they
they don't know that they've made a mess
and so they then end up being
they're treated more like a child so
then you take away their maturity
and so if you don't wait to find out you
you find maturity
in that waiting okay but then what if
it's not
like what if somebody's making a mistake
that's affecting somebody else
so it's not necessarily about their
maturity that you have to wait for to
grow
and you could fix the situation faster
then
why not do that rather than wait for
them to figure out if it's affecting
somebody else
okay so say that there's somebody
there's a car coming
you know you're going to yell stop to
someone who's walking out in the road
yeah that's simple but yeah like that
okay so that you know
yes definitely if you can see a
catastrophe that you
so that's a service that you're doing
but if there's some
but if someone can do something
themselves
okay and if they're making a mistake
over and over and over again
and you're bailing them out they will
never you know you've heard of that with
people with someone who has
never been able to leave home because
their parents
keep bailing them out and they don't
learn how to leave
yeah okay so it depends on the situation
oh it definitely does
you don't do things for other people
that they can do themselves and so if
someone makes a mess in your house okay
they can they can clean it up you don't
do it well that was good you don't do
something for somebody else
that they can do themselves yeah that's
right
and that's it i guess that's a good way
to raise kids too yeah that's how you're
like
should this kid be cleaning up their own
mess well can they yeah
it says a table yeah they can it's going
to take them a little bit longer but can
they do it
yeah or can they do a little bit of it
yeah but you know how much can they do
you don't you don't want them to do the
whole room
you don't want them to vacuum they can't
push the vacuum but scarlett can push a
vacuum
scarlett can push she could do
everything three years old
three years old yeah
wow yeah she loves vacuuming that's she
goes and gets the vacuum out of
out of the laundry room yeah in vacuums
uh-huh
okay next question there's a lot here
we're not going to get something wrong
oh let's try it
um okay this is a good one
when do you stop looking for a mate
like how do you know what do you mean
when you stop looking well i mean
i don't mean what age i mean are there
signs that you know when to stop looking
for somebody
because you said you can't well you
can't find everything you want in one
person
right so how do you know when to stop
how do you know when the person you're
with
is good enough or whether or not they're
not and you should find someone who's
like a little bit better a little bit
closer to what you're looking for
well often you're coming to
the relationship with a set of
ideals and a set of
your own limitations
and so you're looking for a partner that
fulfills some of those limitations
that you're bringing to your
relationship and so when you choose
someone
you're always going to be choosing
someone
based on really what you need in the
moment
and so you're going to feel the most um
satisfaction if you choose someone
who does that who fulfills something in
you
that you feel is that you're not
fulfilling or
or sometimes people choose someone who's
just like them
so they're but
often you choose someone who's different
than you
and who's fulfilling something in you
that you
aspire to be so you you you know you
kind of look up to it so for instance
i choose show someone who's quite a bit
more extroverted than me
um and he probably chose me because i'm
way more physical
way more comfortable with my physical
movements and
and what i do in the physical world that
he is way more comfortable
being being on earth yeah yeah i'm very
comfortable with being on earth so
that might have been woody i'm not that
comfortable being on earth
i think andre's more comfortable being
on earth than i am
well i'm i'm pretty comfortable with
being on earth or at least i have been
and so i think that then they'll
resonate with you and then you think oh
i found the person
but then you grow and you're married and
things change and
you have to grow with one another and
learn from one another and
and then and try to learn about yourself
mostly so that you can become a better
person as you age
why is that not to be the downer but
like why is that better than just being
by yourself
well people don't do all that well by
themselves
you know um how did you do by yourself
were you by yourself or was i in a
relationship yeah
i was by myself some but i had
you know when i moved when i left home i
was with someone
and then i was alone
for a while when i was a student you
know a university student i was alone
for
probably about five years something like
four years maybe it's quite a while
i like being alone i like being alone
but
i know that i'm comfortable with being
alone partly because
i was the youngest of four kids and my
sibling was five years i was alone
she was five years older than me so i
was alone as a little kid
so i got so i was really used to being
alone and i got
good at it because i was so i chose i
would choose to be alone
but that doesn't mean it was good for me
and
in fact when there's people around i'm
happier
i i can be alone like kovit hasn't been
a big problem for me because i
do yoga i meditate i do art i do all
this stuff that's
just more interesting yeah i do alone
things i
hate covid yeah i don't mind
but i have a house i get to go in the
backyard i get to
i have a husband that i live with i have
a couple of friends in my
bubble i have my daughter and my son in
my bubble i don't okay well that's not
alone
no i'm not alone now now though but
there was part of it
part of this julian yeah yeah oh yeah i
did a lot of yoga
you did a lot of yoga right i really did
a lot of zoom
a lot a lot of zoom yoga and i was alone
a lot
yeah i mean it was challenging there's
no doubt about it it was challenging
and i spent a lot of time in prayer
and i did a lot of work on myself
okay so we should probably get into that
a bit because i think a lot of the
response i had from last episode was
you know we went into your background
and then you started on this whole
spiritual thing and people were like
well
what was that about though you just
ended it like you had to go somewhere so
i had to kick you out
right when you got into like the juicy
stuff yeah so i guess this work on
yourself
didn't expect that i didn't expect that
it was a surprise yeah it's been a
surprise what i've
what i've done and of course you know
getting sick and having
a a revelation during the time that i
was ill that completely changed my
attitude to what is
what is the revelation that you had
exactly like um
put it into words yeah it's it's i i
talked to this
you know to someone else who's had a
similar experience to me and we agreed
that it's very hard to talk about
because it's not of the third dimension
it's of the fourth dimension
so it makes it really hard to talk about
anyway i'll try to talk about it so when
i was
when i was given 11 months to live and i
went to the doctor and he told me i was
given
11 months to live and i came home and i
told
you and julian
the i think it was the
the profound love i had for you both
was enough for me to
realize that and i also think it was the
150 lectures i went to with jordan
and listened to him i really do i think
that maybe set me up for this
because he had talked so much about
living
a good life you know he talked so much
about that that i was
primed i think maybe for a spiritual
experience
anyway so i looked at you guys and i
thought
i didn't even think it was like i just
realized all said oh no i'm not this is
not
my attitude isn't right like however i'm
looking at life
that's not how you look at life and be
successful
this has got to change right now i have
to take
what i was thinking was that i was
choosing
who i was and how my life would go
and that that was okay but now i
see that when
life is finite and you only have today
really but
you never live that way right because it
doesn't ever seem that way so i have 11
months that's like
a day i have a day left what am i going
to do with this day
i am going to be there for
the ones i love
and it just became apparent to me that
there was nothing else
in it for me that i have to
be there okay for the one time by that
is that
do whatever it takes or yeah is that
what you mean
do yeah like be there be so present
that if i can see where i can be helpful
anytime i will be
you know also that i will be
that i will take myself
seriously that i will do
what was intended for me to do
that you know the the creative spirit
that's inside me
that i'll make sure that i take that
seriously and i
and i won't let my trivial
anxious neurotic mind
take me anywhere anymore i won't allow
it
i don't have time i don't have time and
it's a disservice to myself and to the
people i love
to waste any more time on
indecision on anger on blame
on like any any of those things it's
it'll take time to do that and i don't
have time
anymore because i've wasted too much
time
not being straight with myself and i
mean
completely straight with myself so that
i'm
in line with my highest good all the
time
so it's a big it's a big thing to bite
off
but it just seemed all of a sudden that
that was
the only thing really that there is
and i didn't think it up it just came to
me in that moment
okay okay yeah i understand that more
yeah okay
everything that didn't matter fell away
because you were in a life and death
situation
yeah you understood that you know and
george always says you know the day
that's the most important thing and
people say live one day at a time and
there's all these things that people say
but
it wasn't uh you don't know you also
can't unders you can't possibly
understand that
until you're in that kind of situation i
don't think you can't force can you
force yourself into that situation
i was skiing when i was 17. i went over
a hill
i saw a rock that was the size of a
size of a freezer a big freezer
i shut my eyes i saw my life flash
before my eyes and when i opened my eyes
i was by the rock and i never
went back to see how i got by the rock
because i was headed straight for the
rock but it just
well i didn't know what to do i was
headed straight for the rock there was i
was gonna hit it
so i shut my eyes i saw my life flash
before my eyes and when i opened my eyes
i was by the rock
that wasn't enough to wake me up maybe
you're just more connected to the
spiritual world
i had like with my my experience wasn't
you're given 11 months but
when my skin stopped healing i was like
this is probably this is probably not
going to last for very long right that's
pretty
fundamental like you can't heal yeah
yeah definite problem
but i didn't get i don't think i was
also on a lot
of medication though so that might have
blocked it a little bit because i was on
a lot of medication but i
i didn't get some sort of spiritual i
didn't get anything spiritual
i got just anger it was like pure anger
it was like that
yeah i got that but it it wasn't
i wouldn't say it was spiritual it was
just like how dare
not like nothing is going to allow this
reality to occur
and like i'll literally
kill myself with work trying to solve
this problem
rather than letting this random illness
take me down so
but it wasn't it wasn't spiritual
i didn't think it was it was anger that
well that's what you needed at the time
to get through it
that's what you were given it worked and
it worked
but yeah medication makes you foggy but
i think it might have been that because
i was like i was very medicated maybe
i don't know well the thing is
i wasn't medicated at all when i was 17
and saw my life flash before my eyes and
it all i thought was i'm not going to
ski anymore
that's what that's all i thought see i
feel like i would have gone back
and looked at my ski things and been
like did i hallucinate the rock was that
really there
what exactly happened was there a curve
and she saw it
she was before me and she screamed and
she went by the rock
oh my god i didn't know that oh yeah my
sister barb and of course we can't ask
her
so she screamed and went by the rock she
was ahead of me so i heard her screaming
when i came over what kind of
ski trail was this i know did you pay to
get on this this is in sunshine
this was like the rocky mountains dude
that's not cool i know
you'd like go up here pay your lift
ticket and oh
casually there's a death rock yeah i
know
i know okay
next question oh this is another let's
let's follow into this one this is
another spiritual question
uh you mentioned last time that you so
when you were in the hospital
and very ill and there were a lot a lot
of people praying for you
um you mentioned that you breathed in
gold light
so what does that mean and how did you
do that because i had i had
one person in particular that asked was
like how do you breathe in gold light
okay try and heal yourself so i breathed
in white light
when i was in my 20s when i had a
i had an ovary that they told me might
be cancer
it wasn't it was a cyst right
that they took out but before that i had
the surgery
i was working with a massage therapist
he was an artistic guy
from florida uh when i was just
finishing my degree i took some
massage lessons from him because i
wanted to be a massage therapist and
there was no massage school
in montreal in 1980 so 86
therapy of all time it was sketchy but
i learned lots but anyway so he said
what we're gonna do
is we're going to do uh he's he took my
foot and he moved
his fingers on the arch of my foot
which is if you look at reflexology this
would be
the spine or the birth canal
and so he just moved both of his hands
up both my feet
like this and then all the way down
continually for two hours
while i laid on my back and i imagined a
white light
coming in through my head
down to my ovary
and while and then i spun it around my
ovary like a ribbon
of light around my ovary and it was this
visualization yeah that's visualization
yeah okay
and i asked my ovary what was wrong
if it was it was scared
if it was angry like what the problem
was to not be afraid
and to tell me what was going on and
it's lasted for two hours and at the end
of it i felt this real pain
kind of like an exit out my right side
and i'd had an ultrasound and the ovary
and the cyst were about the biggest as
big as a softball and when they took it
out they said it was as big as a
ping-pong ball
so it felt to me like whatever spirit
was there
had left the side of my body
i can't explain why i had this pain
it was as if something exited there so
anyway that was when i was in my 20s
okay and so i'd never had a reason to
use this meditation again
ever until i was diagnosed
the second time and told that i was
going to die so the night before
the surgery jordan and i were super
nervous
we were watching as an underestimate of
how that was
well we weren't really even there yeah
right
we were so nervous i wasn't there no you
weren't there i was not there at all
no you i literally went to a different i
don't even know where i was like
floating above myself i just laughed and
like
done with this reality were you there
the night before
i don't remember i can't remember well
yeah i was
i think i was there i can't remember i
remember i was there for surgery
yeah you weren't there the night before
i was there for the you came
i can't remember you came you were with
rohit
and you came and you guys had calls
right so you came all masked up and said
good luck at the hospital i believe
it's hard for me to remember but anyway
so i thought to george you know
we got to bed and i thought we are not
gonna sleep like there's no way i can
sleep tonight
and so i said george we're gonna do this
i had talked about this meditation with
him he knew
of it i said okay we're gonna do it now
and it was probably 11 at night
i said this is going to take two hours
so get comfortable
and i had him sit at my feet and do this
rocking
on my feet and i said just
continue to do that and i'll i'll do
what i'm doing so i started
i shut my eyes and i lined up all the
people on a beach
that had prayed for me so there were
lots of people on the beach
and i had them pray and i breathed in
the prayers
and at first i breathed in white light
but then i thought no it was cancer i
was going to breathe in gold light so i
made that decision
like this is more intense this is so
intense it's got to be this has got to
be powerful
so i'm going to breathe in gold light so
i brought gold light down
to where my kidney was and down to where
the cancer cells were and i when i got
there
and turned to them it was as if they
were turned away from me
so all the other cells that were there
were still with me
but those ones had turned away and they
were on a different
they had turned away from me and that
wasn't going to work
because once your cells have turned away
from you it's kind of like a black hole
right a black hole in the universe and
you know with black holes anything that
goes in there doesn't come out right so
it
it was a place of no return is what it
looked seemed like
to me and i i
once i got there and i don't know how
long that took to get there
then i decided that this was too big for
me that i had to give it back to the
universe
and so then a kind of a black soot
that i imagined came out of me swirled
up
and i told george okay i'm done we can
go to bed and so we went to bed
we got up in the morning and we were
super relaxed
and calm bonnie said that it was so calm
in there she couldn't believe it
and we went to the hospital and i talked
to the surgeon i told him what i did the
night before can you imagine him hearing
this story right but
he was freaking out as well though oh
yeah he was
he was freaking out i remember him yeah
he was very concerned
yes he was very concerned like when he
told me about the cancer he was
he did not fill me with any sense of
ease he was sweating he was talking to
me
you know like he he was having me sign
forms as he was telling me what was
going on yeah yeah i know
yeah it was it was not good it was no it
was
really not good right anyway he said
that the surgery went well and
everything and that all my
everything came out with no trouble he
said he couldn't believe how
straightforward everything was
in the surgery and that they thought
they got everything and they did
they got everything yeah see normally
i'd say that's
completely nuts yeah
but that was before like maybe like five
years ago i would have said that's
completely nuts and now i honestly have
no idea what to believe
i'm more inclined to believe i'm just
not capable of that quite yet
well i've done a lot of meditation and a
lot of visualization for
visualization for a very long time well
there's definitely something to
meditation people have been doing it
forever i'm doing right now i'm doing
mindful meditation for 15 minutes every
morning at nine
it was mindful meditation um so you sit
you sit and you someone rings a bell
and you sit and you breathe and you
notice the breath
on your upper lip so you're really just
paying attention you can notice
you can notice your stomach you can so
and you can decide i've been
meditating and noticing my foot because
my foot has
neurological damage so i've been you
know kind of paying attention to that
and you know in meditation i was talking
to george this morning
so you're trying to you're staying in
the breath
and then your mind will go to what you
have to do that day you know
and so then you notice it and so then
you think okay and then you come back to
the breath
and then your mind will go off on
something else and you'll sit there for
a while and then you think oh and you
come back to that and so
and so and heal about halfway through
he'll remind you ask you if you're with
your breath
and if you aren't to come is this an app
no this is someone i
oh okay so this is a live a live thing
okay it is
and so so then we do that and so what
what it is i think is that
you're attending to the breath and
because you're attending
to something your mind doesn't have that
much
leeway on where it goes so it'll go to
one place you know how sometimes your
mind will be that is already different
that's
that's not okay so i did meditation i
did i do these ads on dad's podcast for
headspace
oh yeah yeah but it's actually an app i
used for a while yeah
for a while and i haven't been using it
recently i should be
but it was like 15 minutes a day and it
would just
focus on your breath and it was just it
was literally just like
bringing and he did he does like the
voice i listen to does bringing you like
gold light
like let it slowly fill up your body and
that's the visualization but he'll stop
talking for like up to 30 seconds
and then he'll be like you know remember
that you're focusing on this cold light
and i will be gone
way gone yeah like i won't even be in
this in the city
right yeah and i'll have gone it's not
one thought it'll be like this thought
this thought this thought this thought
this thought this thought
and they'll be like oh [ __ ] i'm on my
bed meditating whoops um and you do get
better at it but like
it is not easy to drive it's like
learning to drive or
learn to drive was way easier right or
learning learning to do
learning to knit i don't know it's like
learning to do something
and you're learning to bring yourself
back to the breath that's what you're
learning
and so if you're patient you can be more
patient with yourself because
all you're doing is learning how to do
it you'll get better at it just like you
learned how to drive
yeah i mean you're going to get learning
how to drive was easier right well
learning how to write was easy how long
since i was 13.
who starts meditating when they're 13 me
you yeah well apparently you needed it
it paid off didn't it
maybe that was why i think i don't know
yeah
but anyway i really like this so what i
do is i get up and i pray the rosary for
15 minutes
and then i meditate because you have to
be quiet
and listen to god if you want to hear
what god has to say
and so if i say anything during my
meditation i say thy will be done
thy will be done and i ask god what's
your will for me today
and i just try to be present and by god
do you mean what is best for me that i
should realize
kind of i want to be present in the
moment
so whatever comes to me that day i can
respond
in the best way possible
and you know because i have a situation
that i'm living in that's
stressful something is going to come my
way
every day and so i have to be prepared
and so the the way to prepare is to for
me
is to um
to pray the rosary and then
to do this mindful meditation which is
just
breathing and
i'm giving space i'm giving space to
myself
so that i can be centered so that when i
open my eyes and i start my day i'm
starting from a centered place
so that if something comes in my way i
can at least be aware
i can be aware and i can notice oh you
know what i just
like yelled that probably wasn't
appropriate
and then stop myself and apologize oops
you know sorry i've
overreacted there uh i'll try to do
better
and then move on so it just makes me it
just centers me
it centers me and it's really good
it's really good i can sometimes hear
the birds singing
sometimes i get that i had i had that
when i was using headspace and it was
really i was doing 10 minutes i was like
yeah but it was 10 minutes a day
i was like what's the lowest number of
minutes i can spend meditating
yeah and it was 10 minutes a day and it
was just like
it made such a huge difference it was
amazing for 10 minutes of sitting still
yeah and i do it i could do it at nine
and then i have another opportunity at
noon and another opportunity
yeah you need that though i don't do it
at noon i don't have time but at five
now and then i do it
yeah well if you think like how people
used to survive
before we had social media and yeah
electricity and everything like
we would have had time to go pick
berries go pick berries like that
picking if you've ever if anyone
listening has ever gone to pick berries
in the middle of nowhere with nothing
including without a phone which is
something i actually am lucky enough to
have experienced
although i was allergic to everything
but which didn't help
but it does like you hear everything
yeah right and so oh and i have a little
book that i bought for scarlet
it's called mindful it's about mindful
meditation she definitely needs some so
i'm going to teach her and one of the
first little things is
you pretend that you have [ __ ] so you
put fox ears on
in your imagination just visualize it i
haven't put fox and then you say what do
you hear
and so it brings them into the present
that's so
cute so cute and so there's this many
cards oh my god
she's gonna like that so much
oh i like that a lot i tried to i tried
to teach her the
like i've tried to teach her if she gets
angry because she gets angry
i can see her get angry like me like not
like
right andre gets angry in a different
way but i get angry like uncontrollably
angry
and i've seen she's only three and
three-year-olds will do that yeah but i
feel like i can see myself in that and
i'm like no
we don't want to teach that so i've
tried to be like
take like recognize when you're angry
and recognize that it's kind of a
response that you're having and try and
take deep breaths
but she's too little so the deep breaths
don't work and i've tried the like
visualizing gold it's too complicated
try it try the fox the foxes or you
could use
fox ears or you could use fairy ears or
something i've got
i've got so many different things i'll
share them such a good idea
okay i like that okay next question
that's a great idea
i really like that because i've been
looking for something because you're
supposed to it's supposed to be for kids
three and up
okay you're supposed to teach you want
to teach little kids how to control
their uncontrollable anger which it is
when they're three right
you know with julian he was a he was he
was angrier than me
wasn't he yeah but we put him on the
stairs and he learned to control his
anger
he hated being on the stairs yes he
really did he he fought with himself
to go sit down okay you have to explain
the stairs a little bit so what was the
stairs it was the punishment
if julian was acting out and he was
being a brat
and you know what that is because it
annoys parents right so it's something
like that
we'd say okay julian go sit on the
stairs
and when he was really little he'd just
go sit on the stairs but as he got older
and i mean
between two and three uh he wouldn't he
wanted
to not go sit on the stairs and so he'd
stomp his feet
and he and we'd count to three and he'd
say don't count
and he didn't want us to count as he and
he would walk over to the stairs it was
like he had
no control that his body was going over
there
even though he didn't want to do it and
i think because we started so young with
him
he how old was he when you started he
could sit on the stairs
he was pretty little most that could
have had to be all these two
on the stairs that little kid i
basically thought two right
at least two yeah he could walk i
remember julian hating the stairs way
more than i remember being like oh
you're
okay i'll go sit on the stairs and then
i'll just be bad afterwards
i can remember being like and then i'd
generally calm down i wouldn't be bad
afterwards but it wouldn't bug me i'd be
like i can wait this out
right well we used to when we was to say
to julian are we going to have a good
day
because you'll sit there until you've
decided if you want to have a good day
or not
and so julian sit there and say do you
want to have a good day and he'd say
not yet you know and you could see him
fighting with himself on the stairs and
then eventually
he'd calm down and then we'd say do you
want to have a good day and he'd say
yeah i want to have a good day
and then we'd then he would have a baby
let's have a good day we do that with
scarlett oh that's fine but we do
we don't have stairs so we do a corner
yeah like stand in the corner until
you're
are you going to be good yet yeah see no
are you going to be good yet yeah
yeah hug yay everyone's happy now
everyone's going to be good
yeah you're not throwing things at our
head anymore yeah
yeah because george he used to say do
you like if
if you're going to be like this we're
going to have a bad date do you want to
have a good day
and it it worked and he does have
a way better temperament than he might
have had because he was
very stubborn oh that was another
question that people wanted to know
is what was i and what was what were
julian like when we were kids
you were uh you were just a doll
yeah you were if we you know elliot for
instance he's 10 months old
and jill and julian just moved to a
different house for a little while and
julian put a
plant on the floor and elliot was in the
room and
it crawled over the plant and i said
leave it and i sat him down
leave it and i sat him down 15 minutes
later
i was still he knew what leave it meant
but he could not
leave it he couldn't do it and julian
was like that he was
he would push everything but you i would
say
michaela you know don't touch
you wouldn't touch it anymore so you
were just uh
a lot easier as a little kid
you were really really easy little kid
you know once you started thinking maybe
it got worse
but you were really easy little kid and
julian he was a real tough little kid
but then he was really easy person
i feel like we swapped there was a
certain point where we swapped
why you had so many challenges yeah i
think i was probably just sick
i think i would have been easier if i
wasn't sick but look who you are
now i mean it's been a remarkable
journey so far don't you think
a whirlwind of adventure a remarkable
journey
i feel like the adventure could calm
down a little bit yeah that would be
good
like a couple years six months would be
good if less adventure
yeah then everyone will get bored and
we'll be like uh where's the adventure
again
maybe a year or two oh at least five
yeah ten that'd be good maybe ten i
think
maybe five five or ten a while
a while okay
oh oh oh i have something okay okay you
go for a question for you
so i was in a podcast um not too long
ago
and something this fellow said to me i
thought was interesting he said there's
no grammars
on the internet no grammar
type podcasts and i thought oh that's
interesting
i wonder if i could fill that role of
a grammar podcast what do you think of
that
yeah probably i don't think you would
want to do a grammar podcast i think you
would want to do
a advice for people raising kids
so it's kind of a grammar podcast but
you don't want to be put into the
specifically the grandma niche well
there is
there i don't think there's anybody
filling that but advice for
i don't know wow there aren't very many
people well but i mean what does a
grandma do
isn't a grandma supposed to help you
raise your kids that is advice yeah
yeah i suppose right they're supposed to
teach you like hey you're being too
harsh in this way
you need to be more harsh in this way
like i feel like the kind of role
grandmas do
other than taking some of the stress off
the parents is
some advice no you're not doing this
wrong
maybe you should focus more in this
direction i feel like that's kind of
advice
mindful meditation yeah yes use the fox
ears
yeah right yeah i think that's a good
idea here
it's assuming anyone is having kids
anymore
people are still having kids yep vaguely
we are we are i don't know about the
other people out there we are
i have two grandkids that's good that's
pretty good i know
okay more questions yeah
oh okay this is a fun one this is a bit
of a different direction
the biker story there were a number of
people the biker landlord
from monday oh yeah oh yeah people
wanted to hear about this from your
point of view
paulo was he italian
he was french but he was adopted when he
was a baby into an italian
family french italian yikes so his
parents were like
five feet tall and he was five feet tall
and a hundred pounds
his mom and dad and he was six feet tall
and at least 200 pounds
and he was a uh hells angels
biker okay he wasn't just a plane biker
he was a hells angel
yeah why did you guys decide did you
guys know that
you were living in a hells angels
landlord's apartment when you moved
there
he was like he's like i want this one
there oh okay it was dad's fault
it was jordan that chose that place he's
like i can out-talk this guy
but he couldn't he couldn't though
paulo and he had a wife
i can't remember her name she she died
she died while we were living there yeah
why she killed herself jesus
christ they they had quite a
tricky life you know paul he's an
electrician
and he used to get paid for jobs so he
didn't have a regular
income and as soon as he got paid he was
drunk
and then he was drunk until the money
was gone and so
and until some of the anything he could
sell was gone
it was it was that bad oh it was bad
but then in between when he wasn't
drunk he was just this sweet
frenchman it was so sad
it's such a terrible disease alcoholism
it just
would take him it was like some a
monster came and just was throwing him
back and forth and back and forth for
like five
days and then it would when he was out
of money
then the monster wasn't there anymore
and then he would crawl back into life
again and it happened you know all the
time
and it was so hard on his parents
because they
they they gave him you know his parents
too
uh yeah i knew i i massaged his mom oh
my goodness
yeah she wasn't well
i forgot i massaged his mom she was just
it was like
she was going to have a heart attack she
was getting a lot of pain yeah
one side of her was just like a solid
such such a pain that's why pain
dad talks about that all the time does
he well
i mean people know about the story
yeah one time uh paul came over and he
wanted to take jordan on his motorcycle
right he was going to take him to a
biker bar
and you i don't know george
knew better than to lie to him i guess
and
he did for sure know that but he said
he'd go
and so he got on paul's motorbike and
paul gave him his wife's helmet
it sat right up here on jordan's head it
didn't even go up and said
oh my god do you see this yeah and then
jordan
turned her then paul turned around to
jordan he said and if the cops stop us
we're not stopping and then he left and
george said he went from bar to bar he'd
have a fight at
one bar then they'd leave and go to
another bar and he'd have another fight
and george was just
there with them what didn't it what a
trip that must have been
what a trip but he did come home wow
that's crazy
yeah that was paul's i had i had a weird
it wasn't that weird i had a weird
experience though i was
walking out my my aunt bonnie's you know
that
giant mountain they live up in
california and i was at the very bottom
i had to walk like two miles up to their
stupid house and somebody on a
motorcycle drove up
and he was like do you want to ride and
i was like yes
so i got on his motorcycle and i found
out the next year he'd died
oh really yeah same kind of biker guy
hells angels biker guy
accident yeah motorcycle accident
those are dangerous machines motorcycles
oh paul man he used to
there'd be a full moon and he'd go out
in the backyard he had a little dog his
wife had a little dog so he had a little
dog
and the dog would howl and then paula
would howl and the dog would howl and it
was just
we were in the you know it was a it was
an attached apartment
and we were right beside him and the
backyards
paul was in his backyard that was our
backyard was right there with his like
semi detached
like a semi-detached but smaller and
closer montreal style yeah montreal
style and
um we'd have to we'd have we had an air
conditioner and partly it was so that
there would be enough noise to drown out
paul when he was drinking so that we
could sleep he was a
he was a while how long did you guys
live there um
until
you were born so he moved in there
when i he i was there in 87.
you were born in 92 92
a long time what why didn't you move
we paid 210 a month for an apartment
why was he i guess he he had to
couldn't be too expensive so that
someone wouldn't want to live the person
on top of us
freddie she was a i think she was a
research
assistant i'm not quite sure she was
part of the university and then above
him on the third floor was
uh another phd student it was oh it was
student housing kinda ish
well it was cheap so it was student
housing right it was quite a ways from
the university though
it was up at marsha jean talon almost up
up there park avenue near california
there's a lot of university students
around there still though yeah
yeah and we liked living there it had a
backyard it had
grass back there it was nice it was just
paul was just
such a wild man but like i said when he
wasn't drinking
he was he gave us a he gave us a present
for our wedding when we got married
and it was a picture of james dean
nice poster of james neon light
with a neon light down the road of james
dean walking down the road
and he'd done it himself he'd made it
himself it was really
nice oh man people have rough lives
yeah and i think some people have a
tougher time people with
their life right yeah can give someone
the same amount of suffering
or the same amount of uncertainty
and some people can't figure it out or
can't grasp
towards anything like i think you
managed to i guess since the age of 13
at least find something outside of
yourself
that you could focus on for some sort of
comfort maybe well you know when my
grandfather died when i was five
and i was sent to the playground to have
ice cream instead of going to the
funeral and i thought you know what
this doesn't seem right you know you
probably i was five years ago you
probably didn't know there would be five
you know
five years old yeah right
they wanted to spare me the trouble and
you were too old to be spared
yeah i was but they didn't know that
it's got to be close though maybe four
would have been okay maybe three would
have been okay
maybe not scarlet's pretty aware yeah
right right like freakish no you don't
lie to her right
no there's no lying to a little kid they
know anyway yeah i don't
i think you i think you you treat kids
you tell them what they can handle and
be very careful
but you don't hide things from them that
are
real life occurrences and a funeral is a
real life occurrence
but sometimes maybe being more honest
just straight up this is what happens
well westerners they're not that
comfortable with death
you know when my mom died someone is is
there a culture that is
what yeah sure i guess people maybe
people who have afterlives
more yeah or more religion maybe
yeah there's there's a lot more death
you know
uh mexico has a huge understanding
true yeah but uh
anyway there isn't a lot of
understanding of death and there's a lot
of fear
of it so then there's not a lot of
investigation but i think
since that time i've been very
interested in it because i knew that
that was important
important and i knew that i was going to
be
it was going to be necessary for me to
understand that and to endure it
and so i spent my life really preparing
for
trouble well
thank goodness for that because you
definitely got some
yeah yeah and i'm still alive
so and i'm living at home with a lot of
trouble
and and it's okay
it's okay and it's very interesting
because i've done so much work
and continue to have to do so much work
every day
to try to be the best person that i can
it's really helping
the person that i'm with be a better
person too
oh yeah there's no doubt about it it's
okay next question
yep it reminded me of another question
on here
is so dad asked you to marry him a
number of times he did
why is it that he liked you so much
what do you think it is
do you know has he told you
no i don't know all the boys like me
except for one doug homie he didn't like
me but jordan thinks he didn't like me
because everyone else did and he just
wouldn't like me oh it was just it was
just a thing he was doing to be cool
yeah he missed out yeah when i was a
little kid
yeah like one guy doug homie
goddamn dog homie messing up my
my 100 percent yeah oh that's
funny yeah i don't know
get two hmm i had long brown hair
i was probably i don't know did you do a
hard to get thing were you cheesy
oh sure you're just like nah yeah it was
very teeth that kind of thing
very teasy i think it's the cheesy thing
must be
wow also you're amazing oh thank god
well no but
really i don't know how who else would
have put up with this
this is too much for me i'm half related
to the man
although i appreciate it did you know in
23andme when we did 23andme julian and i
and i look more like dad and julian
looks more like you
all the time like way more right it's
weird that you would george said you're
looking more and more like your mother
yeah no no it seems kind of unfair that
you can have a child as a woman that
looks more like the man
that i'm not sure how i feel about that
uh
i don't even know i don't think you look
so much like jordan
do i look like you people say you do
people say
okay that could be true you haven't
heard what about acting oh no i have i
have i have oh for sure
yeah what about acting acting
oh you guys are but luckily i think that
we did a good enough job that neither of
you
are like either of us
you're your own people
a good enough job to make sure yeah
diverges from your parents
yes that's actually so true it is like
oh you're looking a little bit too much
like me
yeah better take after your mom a bit
not too much like your mom
try and find a middle ground you want to
find that person who is born
and who they are you know without
putting too much on them right
no you're you're i thought you were a
fascinating person i still think you're
a fascinating person
you've always been a fascinating person
thanks mom
you're welcome
okay so you mentioned last time that
you talked about being of service yeah
people wanted to know what what does it
mean yeah what does that mean and how do
you know when you're not
you don't want to go too far out of your
way that you hurt yourself to take care
of somebody else so what
what do you mean by being of service to
somebody
or to others so not very long ago i
talked
on a
workshop called navigate to 27
20 year old women 27 year old women
university aged women about and i told
them my life story so how to be
how to be resilient in in crisis was
what
what what i was supposed to talk about
and now i'm going to talk to 13 and 15
year olds
about how to be resilient in crisis
so that should be interesting because
that's pretty young but it's not too
young
that's what i'm trying to tell people
that's literally what i've talked to
andre a lot about that that's
literally what i'm trying to tell people
yeah well that's how to
be resilient in times of crisis yeah
that's what i'm doing
too but i think we have completely
different ways of approaching it
so far so far maybe and maybe they're
not that far apart either
you know maybe we have a different way
of coming at it but they're probably at
this
not very far apart probably not
but being of service it's being of
service so
so that's service that that that's being
of service
do you just mean helping people um
i mean if somebody asks me
to do you know to
if somebody tells me they're hurting
that i listen
maybe i don't try to fix it but i listen
okay
um you know it's a really
it's it's a really nice idea once you
know covet is over
i'll probably work in a soup kitchen
really
yeah i'd like to i'd like to
i feel like all the people in the soup
kitchen are probably on pharmaceuticals
they could be taken off of and then
they'd be sane again
yeah that could be is there gluten in
the soup probably
yeah probably yeah that's why i said i'm
coming from this from a place of anger
i'd like seriously i see people walking
down the street that aren't doing well
i'm like
somebody did this to you you didn't know
about you weren't
couldn't figure it out you're too young
when it happened to you but it's not
your fault
could be fixed but some of the people
i'm talking to their diets are
causing their diets aren't what i would
consider
a diet that is going to be useful to
them
but um but that's not
my that's not my
it's not my responsibility to
responsibility it's good to get involved
in that all i can do
is if they ask me something i can answer
and give whatever has worked for me
i can offer to them that's all that's
what i mean by service
is to take what has worked for me and
offer it if
it's asked for to other people so you
don't give too much
i give i oh i give i i mean as much as
people will allow me to give but
there's no advice there's only
my experience that's the best type of
advice anyway that's the only okay
isn't it true this is what worked for me
yeah
and some other people it's not weird and
so i haven't spoken so far
you know because i was quiet the whole
time jordan was
on tour and the whole time jordan was on
tour
i had something i was thinking
what am i doing here you know i'm
helping george
i make every day of his of his lecture
series go
perfectly that's my job you know and
that's what i'm doing
and it's good but what it but what's in
it for me
why am i doing this what's in it for me
and then
i got sick and
then i had a revelation about my
attitude
and at that point i said god if i live
i will share
and so that's what's happened
pretty incredible yeah i know cool hey
pretty wild yeah
yeah i'm still wrapping my head around
it i'm definitely still wrapping my head
around it
okay thank you mom for joining me again
my pleasure we will do this again
okay i have more things there is still
much to learn excellent
i enjoyed it thanks for coming on thank
you